en avez vous assez du changement d'heure
de revenir du travail à la noirceur
saran l'automne déprimant pour bien des
gens qui voudraient plus de clarté en
fin de journée sans parler des études
selon lesquelles il ya plus de risques
de faire des accidents les jours
suivants parce qu'on est moins vigilant
alors qu'est ce que nos gouvernements
attendent ils attendent un consensus
régional la colombie britannique attend
la côte ouest américaine qui l attend
l'aval du congrès l'ontario attend
l'état de new york et le québec mais
l'état de new york attend aussi l'aval
du congrès et le québec va le faire
quand les autres le feront finalement
l'oeil ou qu'on a décidé de faire
cavalier seul et à whitehorse on ne
change plus l'air depuis 2020 mais quand
on change plus l'heure quelle heure on
garde leur avance et bien sûr pour plus
de lumière en fin de journée sauf que
des experts disent que pour notre
horloge biologique
c'est l'heure normale qu'il faudrait
choisir donc plus de lumière le matin en
attendant d'avoir l'heure juste prenez
votre mal en patience et quand vous
changerez leur vérifier dont les piles
de vos avertisseurs passer le mot
[Musique]